[Music]
would your work week be best with an
extra day of rest hell yeah
Bernie Sanders that guy is calling for a
four-day Work Week citing the success of
pilot programs around the world and his
own experience building the pyramids 4
000 years ago
[Laughter]
[Music]
exploding technology to increase worker
productivity it's time to move towards a
four day work week with no loss of pay
that's an extra day off win for Bernie
that he can spend a different day at
each one of his three Mansions
studies suggest that the same amount of
work can be done in less time
which in contrast to Joe DeVito's act
never works at all
we're gonna get up
it's brizz
y I love my Joes I I beat him up at just
for their lunch money
these guys haven't eaten in a month
there's more laughs oh well I guess
we'll just skip the joke we don't need
it uh oh no that's actually good for you
Joe because there will be more laughs in
the emergency room if you get up again
all right
several countries have been testing this
idea
in the UK 91 of the companies that
tested out a four-day work week on a
trial basis plan and they plan on
sticking with after reporting jumps in
productivity revenue and hiring that
sounds like the same spin Biden puts on
the economy and his bike hopefully we
won't crash too
and workers loved it so much fifteen
percent of them said no amount of money
would get them to return to the old
model which is the same thing DiCaprio
says about his exes
[Laughter]
old model
speaking of old model Joe
would you want a four-day work week or
are you still currently doing two
[Laughter]
I have two jobs so I do 14 days a week
of work but I'll say this I'm not
surprised that people could fit uh five
days of work into four days I could fit
two days of work into five days
so I I my problem with the whole idea
though is if you can fit uh four days of
five days work in four days why not fit
six days of work into five days and make
your business more competitive and get a
promotion but instead what Bernie
Sanders wants to do is give people money
for not working but this is a clever way
to to not call it a tax
um
cat you work five days a week and then
of course you have to write for such
five days a week all through the weekend
so you technically never have a day off
right how could you possibly get four
days a week in I wouldn't like it
because
time off can be stressful too
yeah like statistics show that a day off
is the most likely time to do something
that makes all your friends mad at you
[Laughter]
can't take a day off why because you
worry you know it's like what if you
picked the wrong restaurant or you know
what if you forget to invite someone
there are pitfalls outside of the
workplace waiting to get you the more
you're at the office the less likely
that you're going to get into trouble
you know that's true it keeps me out of
I love to work you're a workaholic yes
thankfully that's what's kept me safe
because it's actually my most powerful
addiction right
okay you you're another entrepreneur you
you were more hats than I do when you in
your workplace could you condense
everything you do
except for shooting and clubbing seals
um in the four days a week I need seven
days a week just to Club baby seals I
could provide breakfast for my family
single day of the week that's the most
important thing so you just don't Club
them she eats them too yeah well I mean
you can't just kill something and not
eat it that's the rule right
um I don't know who's going to fund
money for Ukraine if Americans aren't
working five days a week or the fun era
are managing the Spanish siestas I mean
the study they use in this on the
Europeans are only working four days a
week wow surprise that the Americans are
always working more and paying for
everything that we don't get to have
because the Europeans work for like two
hours a day and then take the whole
month of August off wouldn't that be
nice but then Russia would own
everything so we have to keep working
you know what that's a good point though
if if they just trim some of our income
taxes and ridiculous taxes we wouldn't
have to work as much anyways right Joe
yeah yeah well actually I'm I'm
supposedly on disability so I wasn't
here if anything No One's Gonna argue
I think everyone here believes you I
think the trick is it's not how many
days you work it's you have to stick to
a schedule
um every morning I get up at five I have
some coffee I do a little writing I do
some nude yoga then um then I do as much
more writing as I can until they throw
me out of Starbucks
I ask you I guess that's my fault
Joe I'll go back to you like if you
weren't in entertainment because
entertainment you kind of never really
have a day off because a lot more
happens than just the magic you're
seeing in front of this camera uh if you
had another job what would it be to
where you could work four days a week
like what would be your dream job
outside of Comedy cookie model
like they model like for cookie ads and
such and
wait because it combines no I'm going
somewhere with this it combines looking
healthy enough to be a model but you
also eat cookies wow I give you an extra
question and you lay that down on me
Cookie model we have a cookie model it's
called Cookie Monster how dare you
Joe's much better looking better that's
hairy
most of the way
thanks for that so quickly
that was that was a tough question off
the cuff
like a big audience you'll go to sleep
tonight dreaming of his naked Yoda and
his belly here
he looks like naked Yoda yeah that's
what I would imagine it works you said
yoga
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else